of course when we ask you for your
youtube recommendations you get to see
you being a brutal nurse no no i also i
also watch like food travel things like
best ever food review show oh yeah i
like that show yeah that guy's cool i've
been watching for like years yeah
because because like i'm always
wondering why don't you make uh your own
youtube channel she does i do yeah i've
seen your videos
i mean
aside from aside from that one i i meant
like a because i've seen them i've seen
them as well four years ago
about which one the one with you like
reviewing like the the man's body okay
you in the cosplay
no i was wearing cosplay it's just i
found this water bottle that was the
shape of a man's body and it was a high
q character and then i was seeing i saw
that it was trending on japanese twitter
that if you peel off the wrapping like
the clothes and then pour milk tea in
the full like the naked body appears
so
i was so fascinated that i wanted to
show you you are literally the epitome
of the heavy breathing cat yeah
like whenever you see like a 2d male you
if you like the uh after at the dark
tour it wasn't actually nami it was
melee
no because like i i think it would be
because i i thought it's a really
interesting concept with you being such
a big google reviewer if you just like
it's like the road to like the top five
percent or something like that well how
long will it take maybe yeah million has
a twitter now so you can follow her on
there yeah watch for updates but i would
love to see some mailing gourmet content
would you would you subscribe yeah of
course of course
i reckon you'd be really good at just
like food reviews because like i've
never seen i've never seen someone so
brutal brutal when it comes to reviewing
food as you michael like you you have no
chills yeah the whole review some of the
stuff i've heard you say is like it's
straight to the [ __ ] heart i'll be
like this was just the the most
excellent meal i'm extremely satisfied
maylene what did you think and then
maybe it's like it tastes like dirt
because [ __ ] honestly i don't want
people to think anyone can run a
restaurant like in america a lot of the
times there's like these like you have
singles
you can't compare japanese restaurants
to american or european restaurants i'm
not just saying people will move
somewhere
or
and then they whatever country they're
from they think they they can make the
food of their country and represent the
country with that restaurant but it's
not that simple no of course not
actually i know they're trying to make a
living
yeah but i don't know okay so what are
the things you look for when you go to a
restaurant like what's like the number
one thing of like everything
like the first thing you think it
depends what i'm going for if i'm just
going for like thai or vietnamese food i
don't i'm not gonna look at how dirty it
is how do you how do you weigh each
aspect so like say there's five stars
does like the food get three of the
stars the service gets one and then
there's the you know or is it kind of
just like a package it's a package it's
like how i leave how do i feel when i
leave um or
yeah usually package deal yeah sometimes
i'll think of i already it
is amazing but the the the weight it was
rude is that all right that'd be like oh
my god the food was so delicious but
it's just unfortunate that the service
was bad what one thing uh i was speaking
to chris about this and uh we were
talking about he was like oh you know i
don't want to say anything bad about
some stuff because i don't want to like
you know potentially risk them losing
business or yeah
and uh
you know
i said to chris i was like if a place is
so bad that you give it one stars i
genuinely
you know don't deserve they get to they
get to run a restaurant right yeah give
it to the point where like it could be
like food safety or it's just so bad in
every single way i don't care if someone
loses their job because they shouldn't
be in that job and you just watch
kitchen nightmares yeah yeah just like
you said you're like you don't deserve
to have these trolls on the food and
they disrespect the customer honestly
like i sometimes i go to a restaurant
and i'm just like there's nothing more
disappointing than going to a restaurant
and just having
like a bad meal it's like so sad like
i'm i'm like my day is literally ruined
nothing is worse than a bad meal okay
yeah yeah japan changed that for me
because in the uk it is it is like a
50-50 it is it is whether or not the
restaurant is going to be yeah just good
yeah yeah most things are good but
they're not amazing because like because
like it's about the little things in
life to look forward to and i look
forward to just a good meal at least
once a day you know if i have like a
amazing lunch then dinner could be like
dinner could be yeah like i just want i
just want one good meal whether it be
home cooked or restaurant or wherever it
doesn't need to be ex can be expensive
cheap i just want a good meal and if i'm
wasting
my daily meal on a bad like on a bad
restaurant experience then my day is
literally like scam yeah i'm just like
you you took this from me you took my
you took the the only little joy my
money you took the little joy i look for
every day and you gave me an awful meal
and i'm just like yeah no that's just
that's just bad and like sometimes i
don't i literally don't understand
sometimes how some restaurants can serve
bad meals like like it it said to me
that someone went through the trouble of
opening up a restaurant yeah to serve
[ __ ]
seafood restaurants right now it's kind
of sad for hokkaido at least they're not
getting enough customers to
get like new batches of seafood coming
in so their ratings have dropped because
when the customers come in it's like
it's not fresh wow i can't believe this
has four stars i'm gonna give it two
mm-hmm because it's really sad yeah good
night because like the reason it blows
my mind is that how can how can just
like myself following a random youtube
video i found
like i'm just following that recipe how
can that taste better than me being
served a restaurant meal that has been
cooked by a chef
right that i don't know
when you watch kitchen nightmares it all
makes sense you're just like these
people just want jobs they don't want to
cook they just want they want to work
yeah oh yeah i mean i mean you know at
that point it's just like it just it
it's just like why are you in the
restaurant business
yeah that's right i mean
yeah because yeah because it's not easy
to run a [ __ ] restaurant like it's
not you don't have to run a restaurant
to know that that's [ __ ] hard work
yeah so it's like why would you spend
all that time money and effort to then
just get a bunch of people come into
your restaurant hate your food hate your
service and then leave disappointed like
what's the point i think i would rather
my local restaurant to have more passion
than whoever's doing surgery on me i
don't think i don't really need my
surgeon to be passionate about it i need
my my restaurant to be passionate about
what they're doing yeah because you know
you know who cares about doing open
heart surgery i don't care about that he
probably doesn't care about that i'll be
the person getting like yeah yeah
but that probably doesn't mean [ __ ] if
then you you get the surgery you live
and then you go to a [ __ ] restaurant
afterwards what's the point so to me
it's way more important that there are
some jobs that need passion and you say
that as if you have open heart surgery
as often as you have a meal
you know there's a bit of a different
story even even then i would still
rather you know
even be dispassionate
there are some jobs where i'm like you
don't need to be passionate about this
job mm-hmm restaurant is one of those
chickens no no definitely a restaurant
like some sometimes it just you can just
feel the passion coming out of like the
meal right and the people running and
those are the best meals
you like it when the chef comes out and
asks you like how did you like it i love
that that shows to me he can't she cares
yeah yeah yeah yeah because this isn't
just me he's probably doing it too yeah
obviously
oh my gosh
i shake his hand like in the meal for
free today
obviously he's doing that to like
everyone yeah yeah
because he cares yeah
that means a lot i like that or they'll
ask you which dish did you like which
one was a miss hit or missed yeah where
did we go recently where that happened
the italian place
why what happened
somewhere recently i got asked oh it
wasn't with you no it was with the yeah
with us where we were sitting at the
counter it was the state place we went
to the italian state place where
uh
that where we get the eighth stage
which place
the the one where we get the 45 or 48
day age stake
we like
we've all been you've been there like
three times
it's a counter seat they have an open
car we took chris there yeah oh oh that
place
oh my god how many how many [ __ ] 48
days
you know i want to have steak five times
a week i typically go for the higher end
i'm sorry
i was good because i remember i remember
the first time we went there and we were
like but they they gave us every time
yeah they they gave us the menu and we
were just like uh can i get this and
this please and he's just like um i mean
you can but uh i wouldn't and i mean
i remember when when when we first went
there we were like what a rude [ __ ]
prank telling us how to eat our meal and
then we got the meal and he and we were
just like oh
oh he he was right
he was recommending us the good [ __ ]
but that's i mean if if the guy is
confident enough she's like no yeah
don't how often did you go to a
restaurant when that happened never yeah
exactly right
like the absolute audacity but like
that's the thing that's such a big risk
because if that risk doesn't if this is
like not one of the best meals i've had
yeah which it was by the way then
they're not then
serious balls but normally in japan it's
very common that you will find
restaurants that are like max eight
seating and there's only like two staff
yeah and normally you know to to make
pull off a restaurant like that and and
make it good requires a [ __ ] ton of care
yeah you can't run a two-men restaurant
and it not like
it's not be totally [ __ ] or amazing i
feel like it's very difficult i don't
know
yeah i mean i didn't really appreciate
it until
basically later in life because i grew
up with my parents running a local
family restaurant and i didn't realize
before because i i like to me every
restaurant was run like the restaurant
where i grew up in right and that to me
that was that was the bare minimum that
was normal like i would see my dad
really taking care of the customers and
you know really talking to them getting
getting to know them and i could see my
mum in the kitchen as well and i cared
about her food so whenever whenever she
cooked something that tasted off i was
like mom this is awful like why are you
serving this to the customers like like
this this you can do better ma'am and uh
like i was i was like the worst [ __ ]
critic there and i
because it was my mom so i could i could
criticize my mom's cooking because i was
like i know huh did she cry or no she
didn't cry
but
like
gordon ramsay on it okay you're [ __ ]
what is this
okay garbage
she did she didn't cry but i'm pretty
sure whenever i'd say like whenever i'd
say she didn't cook a good meal like she
felt it in her soul and she's like oh
i'm gonna do better next time
or she was thinking yourself you little
[ __ ]
but like so so that's why i like had a
high standard when going to restaurants
so that's why it blows my mind when i go
to a restaurant and i have like a bad
experience because i was like well i
thought this was just normal everywhere
you're running a restaurant you're
serving food yeah if you serve food
that's worse than what you serve at home
how is that how's that allowed how is
that legal you'll be the norm though
yeah how is that legal
for their skill yeah yeah you're paying
you're paying someone to do a service
that you can't do so unless you're a
[ __ ] chef which most of us aren't
like [ __ ] michelin star chefs i mean
we don't have enough olive oil to be
michelin star chefs most of the time
yeah you know you know so like you go to
somewhere else for them to cook the food
for you and if it's worse than what you
cook yourself then why am i paying you
for this meal yeah you know that's just
that's just my